[Musique]
dans l'actualité de ce lundi 21 mars
selon une étude de l'ue rps unions
régionales des professionnels de santé
l'île de france est devenu le premier
désert médical du pays en cause et les
départs son remplacement une situation
qui pourrait s'accentuer sur les cinq
ans à venir quelle solution le point
dans ce journal avec la présidente de
l'ue rps médecins libéraux ile de france
le mardi 15 mars un nuage de sable
venant du sahara envahi les yvelines les
véhicules ont gardé des traces du
passage du siroco ce week end les
stations de lavage été remplies les
automobilistes illinois été nombreux à
faire la queue pour laver leur voiture
et puis samedi 19 mars l'enseigné
leclerc organisé une opération nationale
de recrutement 7000 postes étaient
disponibles partout en france au
programme job dating et découverte des
coulisses de l'hypermarché nous sommes
allés participer à la grande rencontre
au magasin de bois d'arcy ou 65 postes
étaient à pourvoir
[Musique]
je
c'est tout simplement parce que c'est un
texte qui doit être vivant puisqu'il ya
une évolution à la fois des volontés
politiques sur le territoire et puis une
évolution réglementaire également et
donc il est nécessaire régulièrement de
revoir le texte
une évolution réglementaire pour se
mettre en conformité avec les nouvelles
lois sur l'environnement par exemple les
modifications apportées la vise
également à proposer cette
simplification et clarification des
règles édictées pour que les gens
puissent mieux s'en saisir il ya donc
une volonté collective de tous les
maires de protéger ses hameaux il ya
aussi tout ce qui touche aux franges
entre les zones urbaines et les zones
agricoles et là aussi il ya des efforts
que nous souhaitons faire nous sommes
encore dans la phase de discussion
puisque il y à une concertation très
importante qui doit se faire avec ce que
l'on appelle les personnes qualifiées ou
associés mais également les habitants du
territoire elle a démarré en avril le
1er avril 2021 et elle se terminera
début avril 2022
[Musique]
c'est ce qui touche en général le plus
les habitants sait quelles modifications
je peux apporter sur sur mon logement
nous avons des espaces verts et des
espaces que nous souhaitons protéger
important et c'est l'un des objectifs de
cette modification nous avons aussi des
des lieux que nous considérons comme
emblématiques ou en tout cas intéressant
à protéger
[Musique]
les critères qui ont été utilisés pour
définir
les zones dans plus sous denses c'est
l'accès aux soins c'est un critère qui
s'appelle apl et qui comporte le nombre
de consultations disponibles par médecin
le temps que va mettre un patient pour
accéder à un médecin et le nombre de
consultations par tranche d'âge
à la précédente mesure qui date de 2018
nous l'étions à 30 33 % de déserts
médicaux on a doublé encore il ya des
zones qui pointent leur nez alors que
avant du coup c c les yvelines il ya les
yvelines qui a qui aggravent à leur
situation
[Musique]
la moitié des médecins des deux france a
plus que 60 ans et le car plus que 65 en
dix ans on a perdu
3742 médecins dans la région et on l'a
réussi à en installer à peu près 900 la
moyenne hebdomadaire de travail des
médecins généralistes ses 58 ans donc
les gens ne se projette pas sur ce
modèle là
andres plus attractive la médecine
libérale avec un simple un simple geste
déjà ces deux de se mettre la
consultation comme en france du médecin
libéral à la moyenne de l'europe qui est
plus autour de 50 euros coûte que 25 23
on nous met davantage d'un terne
jusqu alors c'est vrai que l'île de
france comme étant considérée comme bien
dotées n'a pas bénéficié des
augmentations
de postes d'internés été accordé dans
les autres régions et du coup il n'ya
pas d'adéquation tellement entre les
besoins des territoires et le nombre
d'intérêts
[Musique]
des guirlandes de bouchons en plastique
disposées un peu partout dans le collège
sentiment de jouars-pontchartrain à
l'occasion de la journée mondiale du
recyclage les enseignants ont organisé
une grande collecte et pour motiver les
enfants chaque niveau se retrouvent en
compétition en fait il ya eu des
bouchons par niveau parce que le
principe c'est de récupérer le maximum
de bouchons donc on a fait un petit
concours par niveau depuis le début de
la journée les élèves devaient venir
avec leur bouchon
voilà à quoi ils ont collecté un maximum
de bouchons pendant plusieurs semaines
et devait venir les déposer dans les
sacs on a à l'entrée du collège pour
pouvoir voilà avoir un maximum de
bouchons pour leur niveau pour l'instant
on est en train de gagner parce que on a
déjà deux tâches et pampi par rapport
aux autres qu il y en a qui ont juste un
tout petit peu de bouchon dans leur
sachet oui on est bien parti oui et pour
avoir le plus de bouchons possible des
stands sont placées un peu partout dans
l'établissement comme cette animation
bowling ou pour deux strike l'élève
remporte un sachet de bouchons
finalement c'est un geste simple de
récupérer un bouchon au quotidien et et
ensuite de pouvoir servir une cause
comme celle du handicap qui nous a paru
importante et je trouve que allier les
deux environnement et solidarité c'est
quelque chose qui qui nous a bien plu
l'intégralité des bouchons sera remis au
profit de l'association handicap
prévention basée à chatou ils
permettront de financer du matériel pour
les personnes en situation de handicap
et donc l'offre aux lumas de motel de
poc de fauteuils pour une quotidienne
que le méthane de toilette
pour
offrir un show que c'est très important
de collecter des bouchons parce que ça
aide vraiment les gens à
à avoir du matériel qui leur sera utile
à l'avenir coup maintenant grâce à cette
journée de mobilisation le collège a
récolté 56 kg de bouchons
[Musique]
l'entretien dix minutes vous allez
commencer par vous présenter et puis
après on va essayer de voir vers quel
poisson proche vous orienter chinois léo
19 ans a déjà une expérience de caisse
et de mise en rayon dans la grande
distribution et fait partie des 500
postulants attirés par la journée de
recrutement organisée par le leclerc de
bois d'arcy c'est une opportunité c'est
une chance et il faut toujours multiplié
ses possibilités de travail n'ont du
coup toujours postuler dans différents
endroits et quand j'ai vu même si moi je
suis à maurepas donc ça une horde ici
même si c'est une heure de trajet pour u
travail ça n'empêche pas de se déplacer
entre bouchers poissonniers boulanger
employé libre service les entretiens
était possible sans rendez vous avec ou
sans cv une opération organisée au
niveau national dans 460 centre 65
postes sont actuellement à pourvoir dans
cette enseigne un premier échange qui
permet de de d'accrocher sur certains
sur certains points et de pouvoir le cas
échéant s'ils allaient profils sont sûr
intéressant pour nous les revoir sur un
deuxième un deuxième entretien un peu
plus approfondie le but c'était un de
toucher un maximum de personnes j'ai
envie de dire un minimum de temps pour
pouvoir répondre à nos besoins des
visites des coulisses de l'hypermarché
étaient aussi proposées lors de cette
journée des cdi des cdd ou encore de
l'alternance était proposée pour les
eaux le recruteur envisage de le
rappeler d'ici 15 jours pour un nouvel
entretien
[Musique]
3 2 1 0 bonjour à tous vous entrez dans
le studio troisième séance
d'enregistrement pour agnès bottom à la
directrice de cabinet de
voisins-le-bretonneux donnent de la voix
depuis janvier pour informer les
habitants un format à retrouver sur le
site internet de la ville chaque mois
vous impliquer et en savoir plus le cas
c'est encore une autre façon de
communiquer toujours de l'oral
et on sait quelque chose qui ont qui est
facile à écouter puisqu'on peut on peut
l'emmener avec soin dans le train sur
son trajet pour aller au travail par
exemple
et donc c'est un format court et simple
pour donner un maximum d'informations
au sommaire ce mois ci du jardinage avec
les agents des espaces verts de la ville
des découvertes enregistrées aussi sur
le terrain pour ce mois de mars à mios
bottes thomas fait partager le quotidien
et la passion de frédéric des espaces
verts de la commune pour faire découvrir
les métiers des agents de la ville parce
que je pense que les chinois ne
connaissent pas bien ne se rendent pas
vraiment compte eh bien on va sur le
terrain
c'est sur le terrain qu'on voit là qu'on
sent les choses qu'on ressent les choses
et que la personne qui va nous répondre
là j'en ai mais il sera beaucoup plus
impliqués et il nous racontera vraiment
son métier le numéro de mars est en
cours de montage 10 minutes à retrouver
bientôt sur le site internet de la ville
et ses réseaux sociaux
[Musique]
les stations de lavage sont bondées
après le passage du nuage de sable en
provenance du sahara les automobilistes
yvelinois été nombreux à faire la queue
pour laver leur voiture parce qu'avec là
le vent du revenu du sahara ça met une
petite couche de particules de sable sur
la plupart des véhicules dont convient
touche laver notre d'autres voitures ah
oui oui surpris par le membre du coup il
ya vraiment plein de gens et c'est la
filiale a que d'attentes là il ya cinq
minutes que j'attends mais je pense que
ça va durer un petit moment je pas si
vous avez regardé les voitures que kia
sur le parking en ce moment là l'écart
chers vont faire leur business d'après
le pro le patron si la guerre
donc il ya beaucoup de nous et on n'est
pas pressé c'est dimanche il fait beau
je vais pas passer la journée non plus
ici mais quand il faut il faut donc on
passe sur chacun son tour dans cette
station de lavage deux camps ceux qui
préfère laver leur voiture eux mêmes à
la main et ceux qui préfèrent des
rouleaux automatique en fonction du
véhicule là dessus
l'eau ça nettoie un peu plus hier de
manière un peu plus propre j'estime et
aussi effectivement un peu être
feignantise
comme ça ça m'évite de me remettre un
peu partout dans la voiture était propre
elle s'est pris le sable donc éviter
d'ailleurs de passer le rouleau avec le
sable avant c'était rouleau ils sont en
nylon et maintenant ils sont pas
homogènes ils ont voté un tissu donc ça
raymond la voiture pour le gérant de la
station pas facile de faire face à
l'afflux de personnes il ya quatre jours
et depuis c'est 24/24 que le chantier
tourne et bas nous on a des heures a pu
en finir non plus en plus en technique
c'est un petit peu compliqué parce qu'on
n'arrive pas à assumer l'ensemble au
niveau de l'eau on a un forage mais le
forage est tombé en panne ça fait qu'on
a notre ville et on n'a pas assez
pression donc on objet de bloquer une
piste sur deux est le portique de lavage
obligé de faire une série d'attentats à
peu près de 2 8 à 10 voitures est on
obligé que les véhicules l'espace de
quatre minutes et pour ceux qui n'ont
pas encore laver leur voiture il est
préférable de ne pas attendre trop
longtemps car le sable peut endommager
le moteur et la carrosserie
[Musique]
la remise de prix du concours
départemental villes et villages fleuris
s'est déroulée ce vendredi 18 mars les
communes de blainville le gaillard et
réseaux ont obtenu officiellement le
label saint nom la bretèche remporte sa
seconde fleur et chambourcy sa troisième
les communes sont évalués selon
plusieurs critères les niveaux de
fleurissement la gestion et
l'aménagement des espaces publics
objectif de la démarche améliorer la
qualité de vie agir pour l'écologie et
l'environnement ou encore promouvoir
l'image et l'attractivité des villes et
villages avec deux nouvelles villes à
son palmarès et le département des
yvelines comptait 68 communes
labellisées en 2021
[Musique]